Transcriber:
So today I'm going to talk
about the word goodwill.
Goodwill, did you know,
is a technical accounting term.
It's an asset
that's literally only created
when a buyer shows up
and pays a purchase price for a company
that's more than the fair value
of that company's net assets.
So this unexplained differential
is named goodwill.
And with it, accountants actually
can make balance sheets balance.
Now, of course, this isn't how
most of us think of goodwill.
We experience the more human
definition of goodwill.
And I remember very clearly
when that definition
first entered my life.
It was 1976,
and I was five years old.
And I was sitting there one morning
in kindergarten class
when in walked the father
and older siblings of one of my friends.
And they handed me a present.
They gave me a little toy red helicopter,
that sort of looked like this.
And in the moment,
I didn't really understand
why they were giving it to me.
I just remember sensing
that they were happy
and sad at the same time.
And it wasn't only until much later
that I had my aha moment.
That my friend had lost his mom recently,
and that this gift, it was a thank you,
because I would often
share my lunch with my friend
on the many days
that he would come to school
without any lunch of his own.
And over time, as things happen,
I lost the toy,
but I never forgot the lesson
and especially how it made me feel.
My friend's father had rewarded kindness
without cheapening it,
and he made it tangible with an object,
and he made it human in that exchange,
and he made it shareable with this story.
And in doing all of this,
he created real value out of thin air
by turning kindness into a scalable,
collectively-owned asset called goodwill.
You know, and then for us,
for many of us, my life,
the years just pass at a dizzying pace
and I collected a couple of fancy degrees,
I became a dad myself three times over.
And I found myself wheeling and dealing
as an investment banker
and a private equity investor
for many years.
And the lessons from that red helicopter,
they seemed incredibly childish
and weirdly misguided
in the world of business and finance.
Because let’s face it:
non-revenue-generating
investments in people,
they're generally not measured,
let alone rewarded.
But something happened
in the summer of 2013
that would forever change the way
I thought about kindness,
goodwill and their roles
in reshaping business.
I was on a series
of just deflating board calls
involving a failed investment
in a company called Ashley Stewart.
Ashley Stewart as a clothing retail
that has served and employed
primarily plus-sized,
moderate-income Black women
in neighborhoods
across America since 1991.
And I felt accountable
to my former employer,
to my former investors,
to the 1,000 plus employees
at Ashley Stewart,
and frankly, to myself
because I had saved this company
from a near-death bankruptcy filing
just three years prior.
So this time I did something,
I took an action,
I made a choice,
I resigned as chairman of the board
and I agreed to serve as a first-time CEO
of this broken company.
But I agreed to do it just for six months.
I just wanted to avert
a nasty liquidation.
And then I wanted to come home
and get on with my life.
I had immediate pangs of regret
during those first few weeks
at Ashley Stewart.
The corporate headquarters
was a converted warehouse.
I just remember there being a lot of bugs.
There was no Wi-Fi at the headquarters,
and the stores didn't have computers.
And because there was a lack of trust,
there were vendors in the lobby
demanding to be paid in cash upfront.
And because of them,
a lot of my employees were scared.
And so I ended up having to hire
an armed security guard to protect them.
And I felt alone,
like, on every dimension
you can think of --
geography, industry,
gender and, yeah, race.
My first town hall,
it went something along these lines.
"Hi, I'm James.
I've never done this before.
You know, I may be the least qualified
person to run this company.
But I'm here and I'm willing to learn.
Oh, and by the way, after this speech,
I’ve got to head out to the DC,” --
that’s a distribution center, right --
"I've got to head out to the DC,
I've got to find stuff to sell
to fund payroll.
But don't panic.
Because I think that if we can center
kindness and math together,
then maybe we can get out
of this together."
And I don't know why I said some
of these things with my outside voice.
(Laughter)
I may have panicked just a little bit,
but the words were true
and they did come from my heart.
And you know, what happened
was that the people who really wanted
to solve these problems once and for all,
they stepped up.
And it was the women.
It was the employees
and customers alike at those stores,
in those neighborhoods
across America who came forth.
And they offered me insight after insight
as we work side by side together.
And some of the customers,
sensing that we were in a lot of trouble,
they even offered to bring back
their clothes hangers
so that we could save money.
You know, I know what you may be thinking,
you might think, geez,
there were a lot of reasons
why the ladies of Ashley Stewart
might have rejected me.
But they didn't.
They did the exact opposite.
And store after store
sort of worked this way:
They would say, “You’re James?
You’re the new CEO of Ashley Stewart?
Well, OK, let’s go.”
And this played out in town after town,
city after city.
And their generosity toward one another
and their kindness to me,
it just rekindled memories
of the red helicopter.
And I remembered the lesson
that goodwill, like, real goodwill,
it is a real asset
that can compound and be amplified
independent of financial capital.
So late, late nights --
And I'm going to use these
words very deliberately --
It inspired me to compose, draw, design,
create a new business plan
with new mathematical formulas,
operational protocols that were woven
together with multi-sensory storytelling,
whose singular purpose
was to create real value,
driving real goodwill.
The business plan fundamentally
had three concentric spirals
underpinning it.
So picture this.
So first,
we had the courage
to establish a culture of kindness
in the workplace.
Period, end of story.
It was a strategic priority
day in, day out.
And yeah, there were moments
as individuals we failed.
But as a collective,
we were very successful
in changing attitudes
about the transformative power
of kindness at work.
Because you see, what kindness does,
it distributes the joy, actually,
of problem-solving to everyone.
It creates a safe environment
that unleashes innovation,
especially the unselfish kind.
And it turns perceived
liabilities into assets,
which, as any financial
accountant will tell you,
mathematically has to result
in the creation of real equity value
in every meaning of the word.
Second,
once we felt sure about the authenticity
of the internal goodwill
that we had co-created,
we just wanted to show the whole world
and make it tangible to everybody.
So by trusting our employees
and our customers
and by leveraging their smartphones
and their social media platforms,
we were able to scale our marketing
creative efforts very fast
in a very low-cost and organic way.
We invited everyone in,
and we were able to merge ecosystems
and blurring the lines between
outsider and insider,
and them and us.
And we were able to create a seat
at the table for everyone,
which, by the way, enabled us
to leverage the assets
and the balance sheets of everyone.
And third, once we centered goodwill,
we had to center people.
And it wasn't long before we realized
we had to redo our financial formulas
and our financial reporting.
So payroll, instead of being an expense,
became an investment.
And internal communications,
well, that was just a great way
to train and to teach.
And the materials that we created
became critical first stanzas
of the overall narrative
that was our brand song.
And working capital?
Well, our vendors
became effectively co-investors,
and we would measure
working capital as a unit of trust
that we were rebuilding
together step by step.
And finally, human resources.
Well, how could that possibly
be a cost center?
See, when you center
on maximizing goodwill,
it forces you to actually measure it.
And you realize that despite
what the rules of accounting might say,
that it's operations
and leadership and culture
that actually create goodwill.
Not some outside source
of financial capital.
And it makes accounting
actually accountable.
And it isn't long also before you realize
that the entire flow of your operations
has to naturally follow suit.
So to illustrate all of this,
I'm going to take you back
to the holiday season of 2013,
which was only four months removed
from my sort of "meh" town hall.
We were out of money at this point,
and I was terrified.
But we made a couple of decisions
that seemed to have long-term importance
for our efforts.
We hosted a really modest holiday party
at a homeless shelter for women
in Brooklyn, New York.
And at this point,
we didn't have anything to give,
so we gave our time.
We gave our hearts,
and we found a few boxes
of merchandise samples that we donated.
And around that time as well,
we organized a chain-wide
sales competition.
The top 40 stores
earned the right to donate 250 dollars
to a local charity of their own choosing.
Together, these two things, right,
the event -- the party, the competition,
they were just a way for us to
say "thank you" and "goodbye"
to the local neighborhoods and communities
that had supported
this company for 20 years.
And the outpouring was just amazing.
We saw real friendships
that have been developed
over those 20 years
play out right in front of us.
And our newly installed e-com platform?
We operated it in a way
that accentuated that
and connected people,
rather than diminishing humanity.
And sales just exploded.
And just like that,
we had found a way
to operationalize goodwill.
In our internal culture,
in our outbound sales and marketing,
but also, perhaps most significantly,
in our sense of compensation system.
There were all three spirals
just sort of doing this,
mutually reinforcing each other.
We measured everything.
You know, down the road,
as the strategy really took hold,
and I was finally able to secure
some financial capital
and make some necessary
technological investments,
we just did the same thing,
just over and over again at scale.
So we rolled out something
called a CEO Citizenship Award.
That was the most prestigious,
highest-compensated
bonus system in the company.
It went to those employees
who lived out the following credo.
You act like an owner.
Be a good friend.
Be a good mentor.
We never factored in sales or revenues
into these determinations.
Second, you know, our marketing team,
our outbound-facing consumer team
continued to do most of the most important
internal communications.
And I, as a former high school teacher,
I relished the fact that I could teach
the principles of money, life and joy
to my colleagues at scale.
And that really kind of sad holiday party?
Well that evolved into something big.
We called it Finding Ashley Stewart,
which was an annual, nationwide,
year-long search
for unsung women leaders
in our communities.
It would culminate in front
of 3,000 screaming fans
at the Brooklyn Kings Theater
and a star-studded concert.
And the best part of all of it
was that the vendors,
which by now included some
of the world's leading tech
and financial companies,
they're the ones who funded all of this.
You know, I ended up spending seven
years at Ashley Stewart, leading it.
So, far from getting on with my life,
it became part of my life,
especially the friendships.
And we had to make some
tough business decisions along the way,
and not everyone made it.
But our overall strategy and philosophy
generated staggering results.
And yes, it showed up
in our financial statements, too.
So within two years,
we generated more
in annual operating profit
than we paid for all
of the assets of the company.
And our digital strategy,
which never forgot to center
the real friendships in the stores,
it landed us on the stages
of the most prestigious
business conferences in the world
celebrating our growth and our innovation,
only a few years removed
from not even having Wi-Fi.
And it wasn't long before
the financial community,
well, they changed their minds
and they showed up at our headquarters,
but this time with their checkbooks,
and they stroked us a check
that made us convert our real goodwill
into accounting goodwill to the tune
of well north of 100 million dollars.
And I know that none of this
would have been possible
without the lessons that I learned
from my friend's father
way back in kindergarten.
He invested dollars,
but also his time and his heart
into a little toy red helicopter in 1976.
And in the way that he did it,
it created a real asset called goodwill.
And that goodwill compounded
quietly for decades
and then ultimately helped save a company,
around a thousand jobs,
a safe place for a really
deserving group of women,
and over 1 billion dollars
in overall economic productivity.
And in doing so,
he taught an enduring lesson
that helped this grown man
regain his balance,
a true balance,
by remembering to slow down
and to see the world through the eyes
of a five-year-old child
who knows unequivocally
that there is one and only one
definition of goodwill
that creates real value in life
and yeah, in business, too.
Thank you very much for listening.
(Applause)